Bienvenidos a la entrevista de Franz 24
en esta ocasión conversamos con same él
es periodista de investigación
estadounidense y conocedor de las
entrañas del poder de Washington hers
publicó el pasado 8 de febrero un
reportaje que señala que Estados Unidos
es el responsable del ataque contra los
gasoductos nord Stream recordemos que la
infraestructura permitía la exportación
masiva de gas natural ruso hacia
Alemania y de allí al resto de Europa el
proyecto consta por un lado de las
tuberías del nord streammuno en
funcionamiento desde 2012 y por otro
lado de las del nord Stream 2 que fue
finalizado en 2021 pero que nunca llegó
a operar como represalia de Berlín hacia
Moscú por la invasión de Ucrania sin
embargo desde el pasado 26 de septiembre
tanto el
norstream 2 están
tras ser reventados por explosiones
submarinas la investigación de las
explosiones liderada por la fiscalía
sueca apunta a un Sabotaje ejecutado por
un autor Estatal o con capacidades
estatales dada la complejidad requerida
para planear y ejecutar el ataque de
momento ningún país se ha atribuido la
autoría de los hechos por un lado
Estados Unidos ha señalado a Rusia como
principal sospechoso por otro lado Rusia
propietario mayoritario de la compañía
del nord Stream lo niega y de hecho
según reportó el New York Times en
diciembre evalúa el costo de Reparar los
gasoductos en el reportaje como Estados
Unidos se eliminó en nordstream
samourhers plantea que el plan de ataque
fue diseñado por la Cia con la
colaboración de Noruega por deseo del
presidente Joe biden y que la operación
encubierta se ejecutó en junio de 2022
cuando durante unos ejercicios anuales
de la otan en el Báltico buzos de la
Marina de Estados Unidos colocaron
explosivos en las tuberías del Norte
Stream explosivos concretamente c4 que
el ejército de Noruega detonó tres meses
después el 26 de septiembre de 2022
Ahora sí soy mujer Muchísimas gracias
por estar con nosotros usted ha dicho en
varias ocasiones que deconstruyó lo
obvio que Estados Unidos siempre se
opuso al nord Stream por el vínculo de
dependencia que suponía de Europa hacia
Rusia y de hecho Joe biden declaró antes
del inicio de la invasión rusa que si
los tanques rusos entraban en Ucrania
acabaría con el nostre según su texto
que ha levantado bastante debate el
relato se basa en una sola fuente
anónima un factor de hecho de los que ha
participado a este criticismo si no
hubiera considerado obvia la autoridad
de Estados Unidos hubiera confiado en
una sola Fuente
estaba en este negocio por mucho tiempo
si usted se da cuenta
no tengo ninguna cita de nadie en una
reunión y ese fue el tema usted tiene
que entender mi gobierno puede ellos son
muy buenos destruyéndole ductos pero
también son muy buenos descubriendo
Quién fue el que habló entonces tengo
que ser extremadamente cuidadoso para
proteger a la gente
no hay ningún índice no hay nada con lo
que ellos puedan trabajar porque no
puedo ubicar a nadie en una reunión
diciendo nada
pero le quiero preguntar por qué en este
caso a diferencia de en Casos anteriores
confió en una sola Fuente
usted no puede pedirme que hable de
fuentes lo único que puedo decir es que
estaba haciendo esto por 50 55 años he
tenido otras historias importantes
desde Vietnam y la Cia he escrito
Tuvo una historia que era muy importante
que fue muy importante
sobre
estadounidenses ha habido muchas
investigaciones la única historia que
escribí la más importante tenía 70
Fuentes no identificadas Qué significa
esto Cuál es la diferencia que marca y
quiero no me gusta discutir Fuentes
Porque esa es una historia que va a
causar muchos inconvenientes la persona
que describa aquí es una persona que
estaba al tanto de lo que estaba pasando
usted puede dejarlo así puede que esté
haciendo fantasías o no pero si usted
quiere preguntarlo tres veces más puede
responderle lo mismo tres veces más
pero utilizando Fuentes abiertas de
inteligencia varios usuarios señalan que
no constan ni los submarinos ni los
aviones que usted menciona como
Implicados En la operación
las estrategias o las herramientas
abiertas de inteligencia si estas
personas en
monitorean señales ellos no ven aviones
o naves ellos ven señales los aviones
tienen transponders las naves emiten
códigos y no puede trabajar con esos
códigos ellos no pueden encontrar nada
de lo que yo dije pero también saben que
algo ocurrió y no le sorprendería que la
gente que maneja esta operación sean
expertos en este tipo de
inteligencia de fuente abierta el
gobierno de Estados Unidos lo primero
que haces lidiar con esas personas ponen
todo tipo de Señales y hacen pensar que
el mundo es verde y que se puede manejar
de esa manera Por supuesto eso es lo que
se hace con la inteligencia abierta se
convierte en una especie de activo a la
hora de ocultar las misiones pero yo no
puedo explicarle eso al mundo y esperar
que crean señor como usted dijo Por
supuesto hay que proteger a las fuentes
Pero entonces Más allá de lo que le ha
contado su fuente en particular ha
tenido acceso a alguna prueba
La respuesta es Sí y va a publicar
alguna de estas pruebas
hay gente que me ha pedido esta
información que recibí se me ha pedido
que no la utilice Entonces no la voy a
utilizar otros periodistas los que
confío que hay una área completa que
están ignorando
hay todo un mundo
de personas que estuvieron involucradas
en oleoductos
en el desarrollo y su construcción y
ellos tienen muchísima información pero
las personas específicas que conozco no
las puedo ni las voy a mencionar el
punto aquí es que en cualquier industria
siempre hay personas que tienen
conocimiento desde el interior
y en la industria O sea la industria
financiera eso es bastante sencillo
incluso bueno
pero está sorprendido de la reacción o
de la falta de reacción que ha causado
su Artículo
ciertamente hay uno una falta de
reacción por parte de los medios masivos
y como usted sabe después de Trump los
medios en Estados Unidos fueron a favor
de él o en contra de él ese polariza no
creo que no hay ninguna duda al respecto
es distinto
políticamente distinto tienen distintas
perspectivas no me sorprende
no me sorprende que tengamos este tipo
alineación en los medios
ciertamente
que yo haya online hoy anoche haya
mirado sea Google news Y bueno pues el
norte y ves que la historia está en todo
el mundo
hay mucha discusión al respecto
y la mayoría bueno pasa por la pregunta
o tiene esta pregunta de por qué hablo
de una sola fuente porque la historia en
sí misma indica que yo tenía mucha
información mucho más hay mucho más de
lo que pude haber escrito pero tengo que
proteger a la gente que está ahí
por supuesto pero cree que puede
publicar algo que hiciera imposible que
Estados Unidos negara su autoría del
ataque contra el nordstream
en la casa blanca si usted quiere saber
lo que yo pienso yo pienso que la Casa
Blanca sin importar lo que salga no va a
decir nunca que lo hicieron
me apunto nunca se van a sentar ahí y
van a dejar que pase y van a pegarse lo
que dijeron porque las implicaciones de
lo que hicieron son extremos Usted cree
que le van a decir a Europa miren
decidimos que es mejor para ustedes no
tener ningún tipo de combustible que
todas sus fábricas se cierren porque nos
preocupan que ustedes no pueden
respaldarlos respaldarlos en una guerra
contra que usted que le va a decir eso
Estados Unidos a Europa
pasando a otra cuestión de su Artículo
usted menciona el rol clave de Noruega
tanto en el plan como en la ejecución
del ataque le preguntó por qué Estados
Unidos debería confiar en Noruega para
llevar a cabo una operación tan secreta
porque Noruega es un Aliado
importantísimo Ellos nos brindan
nosotros compartimos
capacidades
de espionaje la frontera de ellos se
encuentra con la rusa en el Ártico
entonces hemos construido una base de
submarinos hayamos gastado muchísimo
dinero en Noruega
en su Artículo también apunta que tanto
Dinamarca como Suecia estaban más o
menos al caso de una operación
encubierta en el Báltico confía entonces
en la investigación que lidera la
fiscalía sueca sobre las explosiones
si anunciaron una pero la cancelaron
Estás seguro de que la fiscalía sueca
canceló la investigación
Incluso si no hicieron un anuncio la
falta de declaraciones al respecto
incluso después de lo que haya escrito
de que estuvieran al tanto de la
historia no están haciendo nada esto ya
se ha detenido es lo único que le puedo
decir ha visto usted algo
desde que anunciaron que había sido
saboteada
para terminar Señor
nos ha comentado que va a publicar algo
más sobre el tema por qué
porque hay otras cosas que ocurrieron
que no tienen nada que ver con estas
preguntas sobre Fuentes mire
hay otras cosas que sé que no tienen
nada que ver con Fuentes que tiene que
ver con cosas que están en registro
cosas que explican mucho de lo que pasó
la pregunta que usted está haciendo de
alguna manera siento que tengo que
responderla
no se trata de Por qué describir la
información de la manera en la que la
escribí
hay más en esta historia de lo que
parece y no quiero hablar de lo que no
he escrito
Entonces se nos acaba el tiempo pero
muchísimas gracias por haber compartido
su tiempo y su información con nosotros
fue entretenido con ustedes hasta luego
a ustedes Muchísimas gracias por su
atención saben que Pueden seguir con más
información en France 24 y france24.com
[Música]